well I think they want to get more speed  on the floor as Leonard knocks to three  and the lead is cut to one hurry well  let's take turns at over turn overs 11  to 4 only for the Toronto letter knocks  down another three and the first lead of  the night full of Raptors you want  though he's feeling on the offensive end  draymond Green this is where quiet  Leonard is so tough realizing the end of  bonus you'll put so much pressure on you  trying to create Leonard pull-up jumper  drills it halation basketball against  McKinney with Leonard's he gets to his  spot raises up and knocks it home with  his ninth rebound Leonard pull-up jumper  bucks it in Kawhi Leonard dominating  right now don't a clinic who what where  when and hawai getting it done on the  offensive end  [Applause]  sand flea Leonard jumpers got it 17  points to the quarter for Kawhi Leonard